welcome to the Streamy award winning
podcast not too deep I'm your host grace
Helbig and I'm very excited today
because I have a fellow amazing podcast
host Jay Murray with us today she's
doing this podcast called the dream if
you haven't heard of it yet please go
check it out
it is um about what you might refer to
as pyramid schemes so she legally cannot
say any of that but we're gonna get into
it and also learn a lot about um you
know her love for rappers wives there's
a whole spectrum of conversation that
you're about to dive into so enjoy this
episode not too deep with Jay Murray
[Music]
this episode of not too deep is brought
to you by our great buddies at
Squarespace turn your great idea into a
reality with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project whether you're showcasing your
work or selling products of any kind
with beautiful templates and the ability
to customize just about anything you can
easily make a beautiful website all on
your own but if you do get stuck
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support is there to help
head to squarespace.com slash grace for
a free trial when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain yay Jay Murray hi hi thank you so
much for being here you're welcome I'm
very excited one-eye
not to expose you jack but Jack's a huge
fan thank you oh yeah we've been
obsessed that my mom was an Avon lady
and so yeah so it resonates with me and
like the tiny lipsticks and all that
growing up and my mom like filling out
and having to pay for her own stuff
every week because she didn't make her
quota do you remember the matchstick
eyeliner it was like a matchbook yes and
you peel it we'll use eyeliner to test
the color you know this isn't actually
what eyeliner looks like night not at
all we were kids um okay this is a
question that I have started asking
everyone it might make you uncomfortable
I have a little discomfort in answering
this for myself but how do you describe
what you do to some like if an alien
came down and you had to explain
what you do and how you operate in the
world what would you say like when I
started working on NPR at this American
Life hmm that was like the impossible
task yes if people hadn't heard of the
show to be like okay so well it's kind
of a radio show but then sometimes we do
these weird stories that aren't news
like occasionally there's poetry and
then that's like weird guy in Puerto
Rico or whatever and they're like okay
yeah that doesn't sound like a real job
I actually had a friend say as long as
you're happy
oh man I guess I'm not happy if you're
telling me that I always say I make
radio but that's wrong because nobody
says radio anymore right what is that
I've been working in radio for 20 years
I make the voice part of radio right all
right you do the radio part of radio
actually true way it started but I'm not
on the radio anymore so now I say I
podcast but that could mean even more
thing right holy I mean this is
technically a podcast by standards and
practices how did you okay you lived in
Chicago and I saw in like this whole
like research scenario that you dropped
out of high school but then you went to
the University of Illinois I was a
direct jump from like high school
dropout - it was a winding I would go to
interviews at colleges and they would be
like okay so we see here did your junior
year what happened my parents were just
like I don't remember what happened and
then and then they were like okay we'll
call you and they never did I think I
was a bad investment institution um so
then I just did like I took an airbrush
in class at a community caught you took
a lot of their auto airbrushing at a
community college and then he's go into
more detail about what that is this is
awesome it was an auto airbrushing
putting then like flames on the side of
a
interests no bounds
no I did that and then I mean yeah I did
that was another moment like West Coast
Customs now during the day I wish that
would be so fun yeah no I did that and
then I had to like actually take like
you know basic prereq
and that's when I was like Oh school
isn't bad oh okay cool wait maybe I
should reconsider this air brushing
thing good tool to have a good school
skills have to have in your resume okay
but then you started interning at NPR
right how did that happen I'm a huge
advocate like I school is not
necessarily for everyone but I think
like real world experience and like
really important like I had like six
internships in my undergrad because I
was just like I don't I need I want to
know how to work when I get out of
school well I had four jobs in college
him or five I don't remember the local
news came into the story about me
because they were like see how hard it
is for people to go to college or
whatever and I was like this place is
basically free you guys are my shitty
state school but yeah they came and like
fill me in my campus jobs which were
like three of those and then my
bartending at night one of my campus
jobs was working at the radio station oh
cool and then by accident once like my
last semester of college I was driving
home to Michigan because my fam i
family's from michigan as you might know
if you listen to the dream and I would
go home on weekends and it's like a
three-hour drive and this was pre
podcast so I wasn't listening to NPR and
I heard this show and it was about um it
was a John Hodgman piece I found out
later about a Cuervo man like a friend
of his ok came the Cuervo guy that like
you do shots off his bald head or
something yes spring break I was like
wait a minute
he's like a professional partier right
and I listen I turn the radio on and
this is on and that's the face I was
making the whole time like tis pirate
radio like what happened to my radio
is this and I listen all the way to the
end and then it was like it's This
American Life and then I was like oh
okay that was a weird experience and the
next time I got to a computer I googled
it and they had an internship and so I
just started listening to episodes and
like writing my internship application
at the gym and I think because I later
went on to like run the internship
program and I cannot believe I got this
internship like I do not all what it was
is that I was there and I knew ProTools
okay I took one class in protools
and it was overwhelming to me in
undergrad that I was like I'm good
I'll just like settle with Final Cut Pro
X right now that's great I mean having
that kind of skill being a woman at that
time which was like 15 years ago
yeah 16 years ago I think that went to
my advantage to know that I'm a I'm a
woman who knows pro tools and I was an
early adopter of that one so I think
that and then I was just right down the
street so I could start was like people
are applying from brown like who I've
been following iris careers entire life
and I'm like I did not know who this guy
was
Wow so I'm very very very lucky and then
it just so happened that they had like
some snafu with the scheduling with the
next intern and I got to stay longer and
ingratiate myself further yeah kind of
become part of the wallpaper that's what
I did to us I was like don't be
problematic and they won't even know
you're here if they keep letting you
come into the living keeping your access
on your but I think that's helped you
okay so the dream this is your the
newest endeavor that you've been it's
fully out there now and it's basically
you cannot say explicitly that it's like
I guess investigating the concepts and
ideas around possible pyramid scheme
type of scenarios I can't say that can't
say that go listen to it for yourself
but how did this come about this idea
because it seems like a very personal
issue and very personal topic for you it
came about Laura Mayer who's a producer
at stitcher um had the idea kind of just
vaguely general like this is a weird
world right and she was shopping around
for
juicers i produce for other people as
well i'm not always on the air and so we
had a chat about it and I just didn't my
gossipy thing like my grandma feed from
Flint Michigan like everybody's doing it
uh-huh and so I think they had an
internal discussion and we're like this
is let's get it it's a twofer yeah how
long have you been working on a year a
full year yeah I think we started
reporting in earnest like in January so
I've made multiple trips home
yeah interview my family and other ins I
mean because it's like so nice to visit
my family a workday flight back home
great it's also been a little
nerve-wracking I've never I won't say
I've never done this to my family before
I exploited my mother for views on your
dad my dad isn't on this show
unfortunately but my father is just like
a quote machine like he just does the
most he's just wonderful on the radio at
adore him um and so and I have hit up
friends but like friends who are in this
sort of this world sure so going into
people's homes who like maybe never
heard a podcast or don't know what I've
been doing for the last 20 years but
according to like our superlatives and
junior high I was supposed to be on like
the you know or Aldo or whatever as a
you know as a guest so that's been weird
to have to like do the thing that you're
asking what I would I say to an alien
yeah I know it's kind of that over and
over again like just trust me yeah this
is gonna be fine yeah yeah feel good for
a little while but what's been the most
I mean cuz I'm sure you can go in with
you know when you're producing things
like that it's like this podcast is
obviously just a conversational thing
but like when you go in with a show idea
like that like you have a hypothesis but
you don't fully you can't like predict
necessarily like the entire story I know
this thing has changed so many times
right so you have to be flexible and
kind of move with it constantly like
more episodes are like let's rearrange
the entire order of show is based on
this thing that happened and then also
when it comes out into the world like
because it's a weekly release like you
kind of listen to it and you go like oh
I know what needs to happen next and you
didn't realize it this whole year so
there's just yeah it's kind of an
ever-evolving process I think we knew I
think the things we knew going in is
that it feels a little sketchy yeah
world of it like I feel I felt like just
looking at my Facebook and Instagram
when I see these ads or like my friends
trying to sell me stuff I'm less you
know you kind of bristle a little bit so
that was worth exploring you just to see
if I was being an [ __ ] or if they
were being you know taken advantage of
in some way or whatever so um so going
in with that kind of like open-ended but
like like cynicism like yeah but
curiosity at the same time yeah yeah and
I you know also like I talked about my
great grandmother being an Avon lady
like I have a lot of affection for my
friends who are doing this yeah like I
really like these people it really
resonates with me because I felt it
feels very akin to like the self-help
world like the witch I've worked with a
bunch of like self-help and like clearly
they're closely related yeah and there's
a lot of like pyramid scheme me kind of
you know structure to how that world
operates and so that was what was so
fascinating to me because it's all
people with like good intentions yeah
and that they just don't realize like
the bigger picture what's happening
well it actually this type of business
model is multi-level marketing came out
of self-help II stuff um the guys that
started this way of working were from
like these human potential movement
these like Giants in the early the first
episode century yeah the first episode
of this podcast what's a woman's name
that you interview nan nan okay I am
team nan she can take all my money if
you guys haven't listened to it please
just at least listen to the first
episode because this woman talks about
this thing called the the airplane game
whatever hmm and she talks about it so
flippantly and she talks about literally
like
having to basically like shake down like
a mafia boss on the street for her money
for her kids school like so casually
that I'm like who is this woman how did
you find this woman well she's my
friend's mom she has no actual like
regret or feeling regret in feelings I
think for I mean I don't want to speak
for her I think that she knows they were
all in on it it was her there wasn't
like in her face somebody that was like
you know necessarily getting hurt like I
at the end was still wanting to like be
part of the airplane game Vantage of
this like dumb thing from the get-go
that I was like I appreciate that and
every aspect of who she is okay so for
people that haven't listened how do you
explain the airplane game because I
can't even fully understand it it seems
so basic who described it to me because
he was like a child and it was happening
in his home I was like okay picture like
chairs set up in a triangle okay and
there's one in the front and then two
behind that and then four behind that
and then eight behind that okay you
bring in to sit in the row of eight you
bring in $1,500 you don't have to sit
this is all done on paper a lot of it
cuz it just goes really fast but we do
you mean you bring in fits like those
people pay to sit in those chairs yeah
or to take the place on a chart okay
okay like this is mine
yeah and they pay the people in front of
them and then they pay the people in
front of them with that money and then
the top one walks away with $12,000 and
everyone moves up a line and the end
game is just to make money right there's
no like what my question about it was
like so once you get in the chairs once
you've like secured your chair mm-hmm
dete is there like it can be in many
chairs many airplanes at the same time
but there's no like there's no like talk
you're not getting lectured to you know
I mean you'd like some lectures about
like the new economy and like a positive
thing it was kind of it was it reminds
me a little bit of like the secret
and yeah this was like the actionable
part of the secret you know so it is
like vision boarding but then also let's
make a lot of money well yeah somehow
yeah it was whose it was what was most
shocking to me is that she wasn't the
only person we were talking to that got
involved in this yeah I was like I have
never heard of this before how are two
people that were in
reviewing totally separately for this
show like I got off the phone with her
for during our pre-interview and yes
like oh my gosh you guys okay it's
called the airplane game and then Dan
goes what and I was like it's called the
airplane game and he's like hang on and
went back through his transcripts with
his interview with Robert and was like
Robert did the airplane game and so we
were like crazy it's so I know I'm
shocked that I hadn't heard of it before
but I feel like I'm sure you probably
born yet yeah I was putting on tiny
lipsticks and my mom was selling through
Avon by myself in her room have you I'm
sure you've had a ton of people that
come out of the woodwork and try to
contact you about since the podcast has
been out and like the stories that
you've heard must be insane it is um
it's kind of infuriating because I'm
like why don't you email me six months
ago all right they would've known but
you know we're halfway through the
season and I'm like oh I I totally want
a whole episode about this one lady who
has thirty four thousand dollars worth
of wholesale lularoe leggings in her
garage or whatever you know we hear yeah
like every day we get emails now from
people and the really fun thing has been
and I'm hoping to like somehow contact
these folks and maybe put them on the
show um a lot of people from corporate
oh really a lot of people who like
worked in corporate for these companies
saying I wrote their compensation
packets and then I wrote their
promotional materials and it's a it's
you know and I will go on the record and
I have documentation yeah so that's
really that's interesting
so is there potentially like a season to
this Isis is there two of the dream yeah
probably not about this topic okay we'll
go into other it is yeah has there ever
been I mean I'm sure you've done so many
interviews and pre interviews and things
like that has there ever been one that's
been outstandingly bizarre to you that
like either you couldn't use or was just
like I can't believe this is happening
to me right now
well nan was blind I just want her to
like wake me up every morning and tell
me like you're doing okay
no I'm I think like you know I think my
friends and family so I wasn't like sir
by them but we have someone coming in
Monday that I am like already having
panic attacks about well you can talk
this won't go up until way after oh yeah
so it'll already have happened yeah so
who so you guys know a lot more than I
do
right now but I'm speaking to you from
the past so I'm having a lot of anxiety
like the true anxiety because the the
head of the DSA which is the direct
sellers Association the lobby yeah oh
these companies is coming to my office
on Monday and I just know what to do I
want to like tie him up I want to get
him to bring $1,500
yeah to shake him down like I want to
pin his eyes open okay like you listen
to all of the tape I've got now what you
know yeah but so you haven't interviewed
him yet as of now a little corner knee
and that's what's like the baller move
which I'm really mad about oh so he
thinks he's getting ahead of it by like
being like hey I'll be interviewed I'll
talk to you but really it's like no
you're a piece of [ __ ] so I'm trying to
figure out how to nail him oh yeah in a
way I think I'm just gonna start crying
immediately yes my podcast it's like
making my guests feel very uncomfortable
yeah that it well best of luck it's your
future you thank you I mean you know
it's like it's the main thing I'm makes
me nervous about it is he's like the
closest we've gotten to somebody who
could do something about this yeah and
I'd say you're like how do I have a
rational conversation with this person
but also expressed like your actual
opinions right based on everything that
you've learned from all these people
yeah because you now have to like that's
the crazy thing is you probably have to
carry this weight of all these stories
from everyone and then I have all these
guys in Washington DC and stuff be like
haha sheesh you know
and stomach hurt in a bad way oh man
okay well oh no we're gonna take a quick
break and we get back I'm going to talk
to you about your pure enjoyment of
unsolicited dick pics oh yeah yeah I can
hardly believe it what's going on grace
I mean I don't mean the pound the alarm
but we're sponsored by Squarespace
oh what a shocker yeah did you a dream
that you wanted to turn into a reality
by chance as a matter of fact I do well
we can do a Squarespace fantastic these
guys are our buddies they've been
sponsoring us for a long time and we
really do like them because they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project we're talking about whether
you're looking to start a new business
if you want to showcase your work if you
want to publish content sell products or
more Squarespace is the tool for you
with beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks you can easily make a beautiful
website yourself and they have powerful
ecommerce functionality that lets you
sell anything online and analytics that
help you grow your site in real time as
always everything is optimized for
mobile right out of the box and there's
nothing to patch or upgrade ever buying
domains is super simple and you'll get
the help you need with Squarespace is
24/7 award-winning customer support
Squarespace empowers millions of people
from designers to lawyers artists to
gamers even restaurants and gyms and
myself and Jack Barry I use Squarespace
so I can attest that it works really
well and it's very easy perhaps you've
turned a great idea into something real
how did you know mm-hmm that's exactly
what I did with Squarespace and you guys
get this can go to squarespace.com slash
Grace and get a free trial and when
you're ready to launch you can use offer
code grace to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain at
squarespace.com slash grace offer code
grace hey jackass what what's up this
episode of not too deep is brought to
you by a brand new sponsor though not a
brand new concept yes it's brought to us
by the OkCupid app yeah
the only dating app to find you someone
based on who you are and what you are
into so guys if you're unfamiliar the
OkCupid dating app asks you fun and
meaningful questions that matter to you
so you can be seen by the people who are
going to be into you yeah we got
questions like would you pay an extra
five dollars for guac
or are you too close to your family
sorry I'm reading between the lines
how you feel meaningful questions that I
want answered by the people on this
dating app are you close to your family
did you vote in the last election you'll
see tons of answers that lead to great
conversation and great dates with people
who feel the same way that you do tell
people about your favorite album your
last great trip your favorite podcast
that's a great conversation starter I'll
say and let the love roll in with the
OkCupid app whether you're looking for
that person to join you on a long walk
on the beach or a shirt walk to the pool
bar they are waiting for you on this
OkCupid app so start the new year by
meeting someone who's into what you're
into on the OkCupid app download the
free okay keep it up and find your next
great date today
seriously lead with are you too close to
your family okay let's talk about your
joyous love of unsolicited dick pics
I was asking Jax I was like Jack you lo
J give me some like really interesting
questions that you would want to ask and
he goes les he gave me a bunch things
and then he goes oh she also likes
unsolicited dick pics
all I said was you're the only woman
I've ever heard say she enjoys getting
unsolicited problem okay maybe the
problem can you expand on this cuz dips
are great you know that I've heard
stories pretty much it for me there
[Laughter]
okay well you're funny
oh yeah funny things they're very funny
they're very I mean unsolicited ones
like I wasn't vetted that you know are
great you're like sure I'll take that
and then ones that you are not vetted
you're like well this could be the
[Laughter]
nature versus nurture situation what is
going on yet well in line with that
looks like but you had a tinder podcast
DTR and so this was fully sponsored by
gender yep and it's called down DJ are
down to relation defining the
relationship yeah I had that problem too
the whole time we're trying to decide on
the name I was like down to what sure
has ruined like DTF whole like
colloquial thing now that we refer to
when did this come out this is a few
years ago okay and what was the scenario
of this like that I had pitched a sex
advice show to gimlet we have the the
network that the production house and
network that we made this through
mmm-hmm and and they were like really
good story doing and I was like sex is
smart or whatever we'll figure it out
and they were like no I think it was
like two weeks later they were like hang
on a second actually we just got a call
from tinder and I was like I'm on time
and I'm doing this and so that's how
that went and then that kind of like
launched my production company
oh very good as we made it here and used
a studio and all that stuff and so we
started building like a better studio
and oh that's also make our own things
yeah so no I mean I'm always curious
about people that work in you know the
new media quote-unquote space whatever
like what did you listen to like any
like old media like I'm a radio like I
feel like you're doing radio plays from
the 1930s a tempo that we're gonna shake
around and there's a rain storm but what
do you follow online or do you have I'm
always curious about like I'm obsessed
with French bulldogs and I also have
been recently deep diving into the world
of hedgehogs on Instagram it's really
cute but like is there someone that
you're obsessed with that you follow on
social media or is there like a YouTube
channel or is there something that
you're like this is my go-to honestly
when you have a five-year-old like your
own ideas about what's funny on the
internet kind of yes sir by really
adorable things yeah what is she into
funny animal videos which with her we
could also face filter all day oh yeah
we try not to be on the phone and on
that stuff way too much but it is fun oh
so for short minute and she's hilarious
and so I think like I'm not to say my
daughter has like complete control over
my world I do I will say after blogging
I spent five years blogging you did yes
so I went from this American life to the
hairpin to Jezebel right okay and to DTR
and I did making radio stuff friend
doing documentary work in the meantime
but I also was like a daily blogger
entertainment were you covering I don't
cover anything that I can write about in
the next 15 minutes yeah somebody would
read yeah that I can write in 15 minutes
or you know I did longer pieces too but
that will just kill your interest in the
internet entirely I mean I have like I
am on social media I mostly I'm like I
like like rappers in their wives really
yeah like Gucci Mane's wife I don't know
anything about this she has a wig
company she's so pretty
I don't know and now you have a very
specific go check this out this is a
world I haven't explored before
yeah otherwise I just like hate looking
online that's where I go for like really
sensational new like I read Daily Mail
like just cuz I'm like tell me a story
oh yeah I'm a big deal isten fan yes
just not garbage I love it my whole
brand and I also don't listen to you
don't I was gonna say I mean I have to
be in a mood to listen to a podcast
which is ironic that you know I was on
assignment yes I was like you gotta
listen of this but I got advice from my
my friend and former editor at the
hairpin he did simmerman when I started
working there as a blogger she was like
you should probably stop reading vlogs
really just because they're gonna
influence my way of writing so I did
that and then somehow I just transferred
that over to the podcast so don't really
want to listen what that makes sense
because then subconsciously there's
always a fear that you're like taking
and you're doing cool or like pee I'm
not giving people what they want no
that's totally fair that makes so much
sense yeah cuz you owe a I mean you want
your thing that you're creating your
content to feel authentically like
passionate you know for you to feel
authentically passionate about it so
that can come off like this that it's
kind of like the if I worked at Taco
Bell what I only eat Taco Bell like you
know oh that's okay first of all but no
but you know I mean I leave work I have
these things on all day all day long
yeah and I the last thing I want when
I'm not working on my own tape in
somebody else's tape and like your bad
edits okay so what's your go-to what are
you watching what do you I want all the
Real Housewives yeah okay go down this
rabbit hole because this is my favorite
I love the Real Housewives wedding no I
didn't take I'll was in the wedding okay
and then what emails daughter which is
really sweet I don't know many other
[ __ ] were but their dresses were like
but that's perfectly on brand mother of
the bride dress is like black with lace
up here but wait not cool
it's all confusing every season
especially New York I think Bethenny
called out one time like in an episode
she was like what the [ __ ] are we all
wearing looks like this weird like
goodwill eighties prom dress
kind of not so with her clothes I don't
like funny clothes I do choose you know
I showed up here in my funny pants you
know you can either like look good or
you can like make people laugh yeah I
not to do like the just comfortable and
hilarious what's your favorite franchise
of Real Housewives mm-hmm what's so hard
they're also my precious baby
I like Beverly Hills in New York kind of
equally yeah and then I think they're
individual characters on Atlanta that I
wish I were just like around me I know I
hang on candy oh god I mean talk about a
successful businesswoman an entrepreneur
I think that Sonja is like one of the
greatest comedians of our time she's so
funny
her so funny is she is unreal to me I'm
like I just look at her in the
background of every single scene that's
happening because she's doing something
well I'm like is this a bit when she was
talking about you know just like showing
up to a party naked or whatever and I
think it is kind of a bit and I
appreciate it I'll go into like a deep
emotional talk about her daughter and
she's got showmanship platform and she's
on television and she needs to bring it
oh her and other people are just like I
don't know why these cameras are
following me around and she's like no
look at me I get a little nervous
because I feel like they've become too
self-aware about like their narrative in
the whole series of things that I'm like
no I missed the pure days where you
didn't even know how ridiculous you're
being right now yeah but now it's like
you spot the cameras you know and like
you need to make a scene about something
yeah so it's a god I'm so glad that you
like that that's what I watched let me
think of what else any kind of dystopian
future show or movie okay I like that's
a very wide spectrum yeah well there's a
lot more of them now yeah it's just
great and that might include
documentaries you know but like anything
where like the end of the world is
happening in a weird way okay like that
i also like anything where it's a man
alone that's my favorite genre of any
man oh man like like like a guy
rediscovering himself a guy like facing
a challenge with no help or man versus
machine I felt like by himself all is
lost
no he's like on a boat and which is like
that is what I'm talking about okay okay
whoa this is very specific genre Jack
I'm just gonna leave this mic set up so
when we leave you can just have a little
moment to yourself subscribe to any
other that is so okay so of you knowing
that you have these two genres of things
that you indulge in I'm trying to figure
it out is there a reality show that you
would ever be on no I would be on one
like about hairdressing but I would be
the hair model Oh talk like if there was
something in it for me TV I'd like to be
honest this is already reality enough
for me like this is already like
nerve-wracking and weird oh yeah yeah
yeah do you have you know because um
because you work in old school radio
quote-unquote yeah do you ever have
people that recognize your voice and
like ask you like are you Jamie really
they don't recognise my voice they do
that thing where it's so stupid but when
we did the DTR podcast that face was in
the app as an ad but it looked like a
profile okay so people would swipe on it
and then it would be like you matched
with the podcast or whatever but it was
my face uh-huh
so during that time I got a lot of text
from like X's being like look what up
and again like whoa we are
like oh that's always fun about together
whatever but I think like the occasional
times that my face is men out there I am
like not recognizable I am NOT a
celebrity I am NOT on camera like I
don't this is wrong I should be in radio
this is why are you doing that they're
all made of cardboard but like the fact
that my face is out there occasionally
that if someone happens to see me in
real life they think we're like friends
or something like you an intimate
relationship all why they know who I am
so in their brain they're just like I
this is my own cafe you know and I'll be
like no actually I'll tell them what I
do in there no that's not it that's not
you must know my daughter something your
daughter must know I met you're the
playground I'm like highly unlikely but
okay that's so funny
and also completely awkward they don't
recognise my boys not at all no and I
honestly I think people who are like
solely radio personalities when you do
meet them in real life like it is
jarring like you can't yeah you kind of
can't place it right there face having a
face with it like throws you way off
yeah you just imagine a voice box yeah
yeah that only happened to me one time
up in like Vancouver years ago this
woman at a restaurant afterwards Canada
she yeah it was like the coolest
weirdest the moment that yeah she's like
waited on us and then like literally at
the very end of the meal she was like
one of my co-workers knows your YouTube
videos I've only listened to your
podcast
I thought your voice sounded familiar
but I have no idea what you look like
and she's like this middle-aged woman
that was like not from she was from like
Europe somewhere and I was like you are
not what I would expect to listen to
okay let's say hypothetically oh I love
it you if you were forced to run an
unethical pyramid scheme for lack of a
better phrase what product would you try
to push and this is literally and that's
okay well we had to like assume I'm evil
yes okay so it would seem that your
moral compass doesn't exist some cure
for cancer yeah I'm cure for cancer yeah
like a fake cure for cancer like you
know you know what I'm talking about no
you're done you dialed it on that field
to like emotions and like the fear of
death like I would go all in for like a
vitamin okay and that's how those things
work right they play on your emotions
that's the reason why because much of
their own money this oh yeah I mean it's
like because what's the and mine spell
gonna be like what you want your kid to
die isn't like you haven't thought about
this you haven't been planning this the
truth is like in most cases the product
doesn't matter right yeah it's just
appealing to like the you know the
insecurities and the thirst the money
comes from yeah like it's not you know
like the leggings aren't like these are
the best-looking zevran in fact they're
like those leggings are horrible right
and fall apart in five minutes yeah
designs are bad so why is that a big
popular company yeah it's out of guilt
because you sign up and then you signed
your mom up and then you got to stick
with it oh no I know I used to like I
said I watch my mom like fill out her
own Avon orders and then I would have to
she would drive us to an apartment and I
would have to run upstairs to this
random apartment I have no idea mercy
and I literally throw a envelope under
this random door once a week and I'd be
like in hindsight later on me like my
momma drug to school be like here you go
take the vanilla own child and yeah and
all I knew is that we got [ __ ] on a
tiny little lipstick I think Tupperware
is actually I'm gonna ask that guy on
Monday okay I'm gonna ask the guy from
the DSA Monday like explain to me and
describe a good one first as a bad one
yeah morning so far you know first of
all what do you mean by that like what
do you mean by is there are there
exceptions like are there exceptions
like products that aren't horrible that
I would like yeah I mean we did an
episode about my friend who works for
this bag company and I saw some bags and
I was like these are bad yeah cute I'll
buy these bags sure but it doesn't
matter if your business model is based
on
appealing to people's emotions and
getting fees out of them that don't have
anything to do with the product
yeah those go really deep it's not just
the sign-up fee it's like then you have
a website fee then you have to come to a
training and pay for that and then you
have to you know and there's they they
keep stacking in front of you
opportunities for you to give the
corporation money yeah in ways that
don't make you money or you know have
anything to do with your quote-unquote
business yeah yeah so that's the problem
no I remember I went to a Tony Robbins
event went there and I was fast anybody
I also went in with this like pure
cynicism about it because I worked with
like self-help people in the past and
just thought it was all kind of this
scheme to get people's money and then
you know literally the first day after
like ten hours in a room of listening to
him talk to like 3,000 people you walk
on hot coals and it was like insane and
weird and like yeah you everyone walks
on hot coals we all went back to our
hotel rooms are like you guys got
blisters we got blisters a couple people
into the hospital
everyone's fine but you're like built up
so much about William Patrick holiday
magic okay tell me I'm gonna give you
the synopsis but you have to listen to
this guy like in the 60s was a maniac
and I came out of that kind of like
power positive thinking yeah well and he
apparently he was walking by a garage in
Northern California somewhere and
smelled this amazing smell and a man was
sitting in a garage with like boxes and
boxes of like fruit scented beauty
products kind of like that Bath and Body
Works or something but it was it was
called something else at the time and
this William Penn Patrick went in and
like was like I'll buy it all off of you
right now and like gave the guy like a
ton of money and bought all their
products and then started an MLM and he
was like a maniac and then he he somehow
I don't know why you would think a
garage full of fruit scented Beauty
stuff but somehow sell if you just took
it out of there rid of it he's like
don't it doesn't matter I have a
business model word that does not matter
I just need a product so then he started
a program for his employees that was
like these were office retreats but then
it was
it was like they would abuse people
essentially like walk like bury them
alive or like tie them to a cross and we
can trial for this theory they were like
how did you how did you put people up on
the cross and he said something like
well how would you normally oh [ __ ] how
would you normally bury someone alive
give me a break I don't know but the
craziest thing is that literally like
day three when you fully are like I
understand fundamentally like all of the
positive aspects that people could take
out of this in different realms of their
life that they might need a certain
thing or may need a motivation need
someone to talk to need this environment
but there's like this one moment unlike
the third day we're all like laying on
the floor meditating and they have like
all these audio issues with our blisters
fully we're okay we're healing we're
saving our lives
and then they literally start as you're
like in this deep meditative state
started listening like how much their
next program costs oh my god I was like
this is hypnosis and everyone just wakes
up and goes I'm here's my money here's
my checkbook I was I literally like woke
up out of that and was just like there's
no commercial but anyone else hear that
commercial meditation I'll collect your
$1,200 if you guys want to come to me
with something he lasted three days yeah
I had I was in Florida I had no way out
so yeah they put you in a room when they
say there are you can leave whenever you
want right yeah and that's a little
thing that they're like kind of now this
is a challenge how long can I stay yeah
oh so nuts okay we're going to take one
last break when we get back we have a
bunch of internet questions for you
Twitter it has some things they want to
know we'll be right back with me undies
Valentine's Day is right around the
corner rather than spending all that
money going out to fancy restaurants why
not just hang out and your underwear
courtesy of me undies made from the
coveted micro modal fabric which is
three times softer than cotton me undies
genuinely feels like heaven against your
skin men and women can each choose from
four different cuts all of which are
available
the colors and adventurous prints
including new v-day prints which release
every Tuesday but why stop there this
year me Indies is launching their v-day
prints in lounge pants and onesies as
well both are made from the same micro
modal fabric as their undies and as
someone that has tested this underwear I
can tell you as a personal endorsement
it is absolutely fantastic I don't go
into too many details but it's great
mutinies has a great offer for you our
beautiful listeners first-time purchases
get 15% off and free shipping when you
order me undies it's a no-brainer get
15% off a pair of the most comfortable
undies you will ever put on free
shipping and a 100% satisfaction
guarantee
when you go to me on Descamps slash
grace that's me undies comm slash grace
Jane before we go into the Twitter
questions going to ask you the two
questions asked every single guest
that's on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti act cold spaghetti
mm-hmm
Hitler no I I mean killer cold spaghetti
I mean I want it to be like I want it to
like you know yeah I mean look there's a
lot of people that are dead that I don't
like yeah that's I've already gotten
there you go what I needed I really do
this man on Monday oh you know if I was
British yeah it's a PI thing like Pierce
Morgan just oh yeah that's so good
develop more into this show hold that in
here okay the other question I asked
everyone is to tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story or close call but you can
only use three words or three small
phrases so for instance mine is college
jogging front lawn okay three words or
phrases yeah or some combination of the
two coat
Chella the weekend wine but I have this
I fully appreciate that you immediately
had a story because there are some
people that don't and those people oh
thank you for being guests but I do not
agree with how you live your life okay
let's get into some Twitter questions
here
some ones to know what's the weirdest
thing you've ever smelled oh my god
that's like this question might go
nowhere but when I'm moving out here
uh-huh
we stopped weed it was just like a like
a straight shot like we weren't taking
breaks or anything drove across country
huh okay ended up in a town called
Lexington Nebraska mm-hmm so sorry
Lexington we drive in it like three
o'clock in the morning okay light mist
in the air I see two guys jogging like
it looks like a I mean it's like a rural
kind of factory town okay um and there's
a Holiday Inn Express parked the truck
step out of the truck jump back in the
truck like it was sent in the air that's
like punched me in the face that I
wanted to immediately throw up it was so
intense that I was like I know we're
tired and I know the next hotel isn't
like three more hours and we might die
but we cannot I'll get out of this car
again and we did it covered my face and
ran and we booked a room and as I was
like leaving the front desk I was like I
am so sorry to do this but what the [ __ ]
before she told me what it was was like
maybe a flowering plant that I've never
heard of her sight those death plants
that bloom like one I was like maybe
it's a bloom and like everyone around
here is used to it because those guys
were jogging I thought was something
like that that I just I've never like
spent much time in Nebraska in the
middle of the night in this in September
she goes it's the chicken plant and on
Thursdays they burn what that was I was
like thank you very much I'm going to
sleep and she said
just keep their conditioner on whatever
she told me how to keep it out on
Thursdays they burn I don't know
anything for six hours got back on the
road like it was fine I was gone in the
morning yeah it was gone but I was burnt
feathers was gone carcasses or something
because it was there was a it was more
than just it didn't smell like grilled
chicken yeah yeah it was like it's not a
chick-fil-a no it was order in there not
like a ton of grilled chicken in here
and then I just felt so horrible for the
people who lived there that weren't that
were there before the chicken like what
if the chicken factory just came to your
yard and then was like sorry about
Thursday's your Thursday's are over for
someone I'm sure like it doesn't she's
probably explain this so many times it
doesn't affect her anymore
that's just like their night yeah the
chicken on Thursday okay someone's no
what is your most recurring dream I'm
late because I can't get ready to go do
the thing I have to do oh you're late
for an appointment and there's also I
never graduated high school
no it isn't early I'm dreaming I'm like
that's your life no it's like that dream
where it's like the very last day of
school and then I realized that I've
never been to any of the classes I don't
have my homework because I didn't go to
the classes I don't know the combination
to my locker which would allow me to get
my books out to fake like I'd done to a
class and I have to take a test or I'm
not gonna graduate and then I have to
like walk into the classroom and I'm
humiliated but because the teacher knows
that I've never been her and like no one
recognizes me and I just like can't be
the test and then I wake up so there's
that one and then the other one is
getting ready to go somewhere and I like
my shoes don't fit my pants don't fit my
hair is [ __ ] up like I don't know
everything that can go wrong goes wrong
and then I'm finally like walking out
the door like the sun's coming up you
know I don't know what it's about you
tell me how I was gonna say have you
looked into what he's mean
no cold [ __ ] shower I drink a bottle
of scotch and I go to work moving on
okay so also know what's your favorite
Taylor Alison Swift song are you a
Taylor Swift fan no okay I didn't know
sometimes I'm like these questions seem
specifically tailored but literally I
actually read that and I was like Taylor
Allison Taylor Swift I don't know j-jane
obsession for middle age she seems like
I find she's trying you know musically
that does that who's like what's your
go-to music I like rap music oh that's
right I forgot
right yes we forget yeah and I call it
rap music what's uh what's the greatest
like concert experience you've had
obviously it was the one where I was
seeing my pants that I was just telling
you about weekend I had no idea that guy
could sing like that and he was like
live and I was like whoa this is that's
why it was great because I've never been
to a concert where I was converted
during the concert oh okay usually you
either know the band or hate the band
like you there no I mean you're on board
or you hear them live for ha like five
seconds sure
goodbye yeah I know it was that show I
was really like I think I was crying it
was beautiful it was beautiful it's a
huge endorsement like it looked into him
and I was like okay I'm just gonna stop
and continue to know what's her best
pick-up line that might actually work
oh I just straight-up asked people out
oh yeah current partner I just said
would you like to go on a date with me I
lied to get your contact information
oh it's really flattering though and he
said sure do have you had some like have
you been on the other hand of getting
the worst pick-up line I don't know if I
differentiate between a pick-up line and
just men talking to say but you know
what are you doing what are they doing
yeah why are they so it's the end game
yeah I know what it is yeah I know what
you're doing here has there ever been
any standout lines the cringe-worthy cuz
I feel like you know I'll think of it I
don't know I I'm also not the kind of
unfortunately which is why I have to ask
people out I'm not the most approachable
same no I'm very much closed off I think
in a it mean to be I'm fun I'm having
fun you know but then I think people I
think I I have closed-door energy [ __ ]
is that what it is
I just doesn't happen that much no Sam I
I feel a little like sad in hindsight
that I'm like I don't have many like
pick-up line scenarios and I think it's
because I don't give up the this like
open energy to people in social
situations like I get neg probably oh
yeah I don't recognize that like it
doesn't work on me so tonight it's only
like an hindsight that I go I think that
guy was trying to hit on me but he was
just like being really mean yeah talk to
women yeah I'm supposed to know what's
your go-to karaoke song okay I like a
problem or her trick well I like
something that distracts from me I
actually can sing it turns out I did
karaoke recently and like everybody was
like that was weird all nervous I do get
very nervous but I guess I can thing but
I like to do eternal flame oh it's very
easy to sing and there's not like a ton
of range and then also I can just hold
the candle and like do this music video
the audience will sing for me yeah like
just a friend a good call and response
and just talk talk talk and that
everyone does the singing oh yeah a good
call and response song it's always
helpful at karaoke it's a group effort
yep end of the day someone oh do people
ever mistake you for someone else no but
I get compared to celebrities solely
based on whatever haircut I have really
yeah I'm one of those people that if my
hair is really short that's just like
whoever is short in the news right now
whoever has short hair in the news right
now a brown hair they're like that's who
you are today oh wow
yeah it kind of like moves around with
my haircut have you had a fangirl moment
since you've been out here in Los
Angeles like have you been at any events
or seen anyone or like are you asking if
I go to Villa Blanca regularly um have
you been to sir yeah
Dinah's go to Villa Blanca and look at
Lisa yeah she's the owner pump is just
sitting there - they're all the times
they're all the times the dogs are there
all the time he's not touching the food
yeah and I'm not eating having a glass
of wine and just staring it was like
yeah I've only been there once and it
was like before like a pitch meeting and
so I went my friend we got wine before
the meeting to pump ourselves up and
like just also see Villa Blanca for the
first time mm-hmm
well dear than I thought it was gonna be
it's dusty the W on their bathroom door
is the wu-tang W but yeah so much white
stuff and yes butts are on it yeah feels
very like Palm Springs in the eighties
kind of the core white be your main
color in a restaurant yeah you kind of
recycle that [ __ ] you gotta like move it
out yeah some new white you gotta update
it you gotta keep it fresh yeah cuz it
gets a little dusty a little like
fingerprint e everywhere on all the
menus and I'm like I've worked at a lot
of chilies and so this is just a more
elegant Chili's right like Chili's but
like a bar-mitzvah
basically and they have like deep fried
spring rolls and things that are like
not there like the frozen ones from
Chili's yep they're like great by the
way wrong I will eat a molten chocolate
cake every day of the week okay someone
to know here's a very light-hearted
final question for you what's your
biggest regret or light-hearted but they
said what is one thing you wish you
tried when given the opportunity and
this can also go for a nut like
necessary in the past or like something
that you want to do in the future
um just school um no I I'm I probably
should be more regretful but I find the
idea a little bit of
of like HS yeah because whatever you did
instead of the thing that you did
there's no telling that that was a
better idea
like the not doing it or doing it yeah
you don't know how anything's gonna go
but you really only know later if you
like
that's so true you can choose things and
then they can go poorly but then you
could have you know what I mean that
part didn't for me to even like wrap my
head around what I regret really is I
guess like a general regret about my
personality is I this is a big one I
like to end podcast but like the guests
just feeling really depressed and flawed
no I think um I think that I have spent
I've too many times like waited to do
something or made a decision about what
I wanted to do based on my partner's
feelings yeah I'm so with you same for
me yeah over it now yeah it's too late
yeah I think that's like a huge thing to
acknowledge like that's a big trend in
my world I would've had a kid a lot
sooner and I'm not I would have been
again not a regret not like it would I
better center the worse but Meredith I I
do regret making so many big life
decisions based not based on what they
want I mean I wanted them yeah in the
time that it took me to convince them or
yeah like for you to get people on board
or just waiting a lot of time waiting
yeah for other people who then are like
gone eventually anyway right I just like
fully supported my own thoughts and
beliefs at once where would I be but I
guess I'm thinking X I have a daughter
now yeah you know that's good I think
that's a really like it's almost like
kind of backwards ly motivating that's I
don't wait around for someone else to
confirm the things that you want for
yourself and I think because then you
will you might feel like you miss out or
you might feel like especially if that
person is not there anymore like what
did I do this like why did I wait I
wasted time somebody taught me I guess
when I was a young child and I'm not
gonna say that's my mom cuz I don't
remember but I feel like I got this chip
installed that was like don't decide
what you exactly want until it's until
someone says it's okay those couldn't
with a partner yeah yeah or a boss or
any you know yeah somebody else says
that's okay for you to do that yeah I
know
I am I was thinking about that a lot
with my kid where I'm like the situation
I'm in now
where at I just live alone and he's
there and I'm a single mom and that's
what it is yeah
and I'm working I pay the bills like
anytime but that's done this is where I
was gonna end up anyway yeah yeah yeah I
could have been doing this all time ya
know but also it's like time but it's
like yeah it's good to admit to yourself
and like just keep that in the back your
mind of like checking in with like am i
doing this for me or am i doing this
because my like classical conditioning
and my brain tells me I need permission
from someone to be able to like I'm
always doing it for me but I'm also
hesitant until I get the cosine yeah
that's resonates very strongly that way
anymore
well I'm happy for you thank you into
the future Jane thank you so much for
being here we're gonna give you the gift
that we give everyone for being a guest
on the podcast is a.m. it's a fortune
cookie that's just for you oh my fortune
cookie you don't have to eat it oh yeah
right now you can read the fortune
this superstition I'm not superstitious
I'm only superstitious about dumb [ __ ]
same so um like oh my god I thought it
wasn't in here I'm gonna make you feel
vulnerable I'm not gonna [ __ ] for [ __ ]
I was just crammed in one side I have
this superstition that whatever the
fortune is it won't come true if you
haven't eaten the whole cookie first
okay but I don't want to do that right
now yeah you do you again no regrets
right right this is a novel okay yeah we
crammed Moby Dick into this fortune
cookie some of us may have subscribed to
the dream and are a few episodes in
still waiting to hear what teeth falling
out and our dreams mean we're slowly
realizing now that's not what the show
is about hmm there's still time
there's still time yeah coming up well
with that where can people find
everything that you're up to if they
don't already know um you can look at
little everywhere calm okay and so all
of our
shows are on there including the dream
I'm the dream is available wherever you
get your podcast you know it's true
though yeah it is yeah it really is
available yeah and I'm at C Jayne Murray
ste Jayne Murray on the interwebs
awesome thank you again so much also
offline I got to get Nan's information
but Thank You Jay and dragged about man
oh god I know once we turn the mics off
oh my god okay I can't wait okay bye
guys thanks for listening next time not
2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep
not too deep as a production of grace
helbig incorporated a producer and
directed by Jack ferry producer and
editor
Melissa demons writing by Diane King
production assistance by Katrina Henning
post production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]